welcome thank you very much mark thanks
to the organizers for the the invitation
and the opportunity to escape Sweden for
a week or so while winter is still in in
full swing so I've been working with
information flow in various forms for
quite a long time the information flow
is interesting for many reasons but I
think the most interesting ones relate
to security and privacy because in
security and privacy we fundamentally
care about what happens to our
information and how it flows through
systems and indeed when it comes to
privacy and differential privacy we're
interested in not only how it flows but
in what quantities in a certain sense
does it flow
now I'm coming from a background in
programming languages and formal
semantics so I'm interested in modeling
things in a precise way and it turns out
that this is a good match for
understanding information flow
properties because information flow
properties are tremendously subtle there
are many things that seem to go wrong in
both formalizing them and building
systems which fulfill certain
information flow based goals so what I'm
going to do today is reflect a little
bit upon some of the things that I've
learned relating to information flow and
I'm going to do so through an example
relating to a system for enforcing
differential privacy which is one of the
few things that I've done in the
direction specifically of differential
privacy so anything about differential
privacy maybe you think about something
like this it's some clever probabilistic
mechanism which where you feed in a bit
of sensitive data and out pops some data
which you're willing to release and
there's lots of complex stuff that can
go on inside one of these mechanisms but
I'm interested in a slightly bigger
picture I'm interested in in how we put
one of these little clever mechanisms in
some context so some context is going to
be some bigger thing
it may be involve some local storage of
data it may be involved some other stuff
in which the mechanism is embedded are
the kinds of computation that are not
specifically related to the mechanism
but to do with the reformatting the
processing of data the shuffling it
around getting in the right shape and in
fact things are not necessarily as
simple as this typically when we have a
system we have some other data in the
system there isn't just the sensitive
data and nothing else
there's often other data which is not
sensitive which we maybe can use freely
and one of the ways in which we use that
data freely is for example we might want
to store the results of previous
computer
now we look at a bit about the green
stuff here the green stuff is the way we
take building blocks these mechanisms
and plug them together in various ways
to build our system and so we maybe
you're doing that in some principled way
hopefully and we may indeed as I
mentioned have some kind of feedback in
this loop this is an interactive or a
system which runs over time it's not
just a simple function with a single
input and a single output it has an
iterative ongoing behavior and that
behavior may involve various forms of
feedback and in fact one of the most
obvious forms of feedback in a system
enforcing differential privacy is that
one of the pieces of typically public
data is the budget which is affected by
the computation in various ways so I
would say that if we take a slightly
bigger view of differential privacy
we're looking at a system which is
potentially a little bit more complex
than the idealized models and one in
which there are a number of potentially
interesting and potentially problematic
information flows that we have to
understand so I want to tell you a
little bit by way of illustrating some
more general observations a little bit
about a differential privacy mechanism
which was by and large invented by my
former student Hameed so and we'd came
up with this idea completely independent
of me of pretty much anybody I would say
as a master student he implemented a
system for dynamically enforcing
differential privacy rather much in the
style of the pink system of McSherry
I'll say a few words about that shortly
but doing something really unusual
namely replacing the idea of a global
budget for the database with a per user
budget
so my first reaction to this is that
can't possibly work because if it's a
per user budget then somehow that's
going to be influenced by the data of
the user and if your budget is
influenced by the data of the user that
just doesn't feel quite right that's a
sort of thing when you look at the
literature everybody always avoids I
mean think local sensitivity why don't
you use local sensitivity well because
the noise is specific to the data so if
you use that noise you potentially
reveal something about the data so this
sounded terribly wrong to me but at the
same time for me this was terribly
obvious it's obvious that this would
would work would work would not be a
problem so he's a rather fit looking
chap so we couldn't really take it
outside so I think the best way I
thought to resolve this would be to try
and build a formal model of what he was
trying to do in that way I could
understand it better and we together
could maybe prove that it really does
indeed satisfy the differential privacy
property that we that he certainly
expected it to and I certainly was very
dubious about so let me tell you a
little bit about pink before I get into
a little bit more detail about this
system was there a question there so his
user here at dinner subjected the
analyst a data subject is the user in
this in this code yes very I've got a
very natural question indeed sorry for
the lack of clarity per user as in data
subject okay so let me tell you about
pink pink was one of the first systems
which attempted to make the construction
of somewhat new differential private
algorithms idiot-proof in the privacy
sense that is to say you've given a
bunch of building blocks a bunch of
basic differentially private mechanisms
and you can program with them but the
programming model keeps track of
important security related features
in particular when you transform data
you really need to know what the
sensitivity of the resulting database is
because that is a multiplier for the
privacy cost when you apply a basic
epsilon query to that piece of data
so what pink actually provides you with
is an API it's an interface to a
protected implementation so there's data
in the system namely a global privacy
budget which is assigned to the data and
for every intermediate table that's
constructed from the initial data the
system automatically keeps track of the
sensitivity or stability as I think
McSherry called it in this context of
the intermediate tables so that's
roughly the way it works and the
bookkeeping is to make sure that you you
use the sensitivity to calculate the
appropriate privacy cost of a given
query and if there isn't enough budget
left the analyst can't make a mistake
the system just said says no sorry sorry
Dave I can't do that okay so that's pink
so the the motivation for moving to a
personalized budget personalizing the
data subjects point of view can be
motive can be thought of in the
following way and you may be able to
come up with other possible motivations
but here's here the ones that we were
thinking about so firstly if you don't
plan the use of your budget in a smart
way you can end up being extremely
wasteful in pink and sometimes it's not
always easy to plan in advance how
you're going to use your budget for
example if you were to divide up your
budget between different analysts who
are in some sense independent then it
may not be necessarily very easy to make
a plan a global plan for coordinating
the potentially overlapping queries of
two different parties in order to ensure
the best possible use of your budget so
in this example let's imagine that I
have a big data set
and I'm interested in doing a particular
survey of people with a B negative blood
blood type a B negative naught point six
percent of the population now as far as
pink is concerned the size of the
population is really not doesn't come
into play there's a global budget if I
analyze the hell out of the this group
of a B negative
subjects my global budget will be gone
so that when analyst number two comes
along on Tuesday and says oh yeah how
did the out of the a B negative
survey go oh yeah great got some great
great stats on that one yeah right well
today I'm gonna do some study over all
the adults in this fantastic dataset now
I'm sorry I'm sorry buddy I've used up
all the budget used up all the budget on
nought point six percent of the
population that's not great another
scenario where a global budget is
problematic is where you have continuous
data you have data you have a database
which is which is not static okay so at
some point in time that's this is the
data we've got we can analyze it a bit
but as time goes on some records
disappear some new records come in if
you have a global budget we would have
to somehow divide up into epochs we
couldn't analyze the data continuously
we'd have to sort of say okay this is
the 2000 2010 census this is the 2020
and for all intensive purposes we view
these as separate things so we couldn't
do this continuously over time so both
of these issues are motivation for
having a personalised budget but if you
have a personalized budget you can focus
if we're only doing survey on on
individuals with a particular
characteristic they're the only ones
whose privacy potentially is affected
now you may be thinking that sounds of
fishy that's good I always I also think
this sounds very fishy
which is why it's extremely important if
you have a system like this that smells
a bit fishy to really work out what it's
doing what kind of properties are you
really satisfying
okay so I'll get into that into a moment
so let me just tell you about
personalized differential privacy so
this was the definition of differential
privacy in which individuals have their
own personal Epsilon interestingly
within a month of us publishing there
was another paper using the same concept
of personalized differential privacy
with exactly the same definition that
was really cool and we were no no
knowledge of each other's work the
enforcement mechanisms are entirely
different so that was where the
similarity ended so personalized
differential privacy is a genuine
generalization of differential privacy
in which each individual has their own
personal Epsilon now I'm not
particularly interested in allowing
individuals to set their own Epsilon
that's not the goal here this is really
as a means to do a more fine-grained
accounting of the budget so for present
purposes you can imagine everybody
starts with the same epsilon and at the
top level that's going to imply regular
epsilon differential privacy but the
ability to have fine grain budgets will
give us the ability to account for the
budget in a more fine-grained way so we
can show then that the basic composition
principles that McSherry used to build
his system also hold in a more
generalized form in the individual case
that's great we have the same building
blocks
but what we do which is different is
implement personalized differential
privacy by tracking the exact provenance
of every record in every intermediate
table that we construct so any table
that we construct along the way however
we do it we will know for every record
in that table which individuals was that
record built from so what we get then is
an extremely fine-grained notion of
sensitivity we know exactly what the
dependencies are and their
multiplicities most importantly and we
can use that to know how much and how
many times we should deduct an epsilon
from the individual budgets of the
participants in a query so we visualize
that with a picture ask a question back
on that site yeah what's the definition
of neighboring databases so we're just
using unbounded differential privacy
regular differential privacy epsilon to
neighbouring databases if you add or
remove a given record what's the
universe from which those databases are
selected it's not it's not specified a
these are these are just some relational
database tables in the implementation
comes with that person so there is some
way of uniquely identifying the epsilon
for a given record so you could imagine
that every record maybe carry some
identifier that allows you entity has
its own epsilon already assigned yeah
it's this kind of kind of set at a meta
level yeah so here's a little table with
a bunch of people and there's some
initial budget and that's I say let's
just put the same budget and everyone
I'm not I'm not particularly interested
in it exotic guarantees just going to
guarantee one differential privacy in
this case we may do some comp
patient on this table select all the
ages of the adults all the adult ages
there's a transformation on the table
that generates an intermediate table
well you notice about the intermediate
table well there's some colors on it
those colors are representing the
provenance that is to say that this
record is derived from Mary and this one
is derived from Bob so now when we
perform a query on this some primitive
differential private query that the
system provides us with from its toolbox
we can calculate say the average but we
can also update the budget and we do so
by looking at the provenance of the
tables and the multiplicities of those
prompt provenances and deducting
correspondingly from the personal
budgets what could possibly go wrong
well there is a catch
you see systems for differential privacy
they don't measure privacy they enforce
privacy and there's an important
difference there because when you
enforce privacy you sometimes have to in
some way say no and that decision is an
important carrier of information you
can't ignore it so if you model a system
like this as one which doesn't enforce
privacy but just measures it then things
become a lot easier but they in some
sense become unrealistic because that's
not what we want to do typically we do
want to enforce an a priori bound on our
privacy okay so the catch is in pink if
you run out of the global budget you
deny the query you throw an exception
and that's okay because the budget is
not private it's not sensitive
however improper the budget is very much
a private thing the fact that your
budget went down is because you
participated in a query and the reason
you pass it if it participated in the
query tells you about you so if you
participated in that query just now we
know you're an adult so if we can see
your budget we know something about you
we know a fact about you so we have to
accept that the budget cannot be private
that means we can't leak the budget so
what do we do of a solution is that we
if an individual would run out of budget
when we do a query then we say okay in
that table which would cause that
individual privacy harm we will remove
all the records which depend on that
individual so we will remove them and
silently drop them from the table so
that way we make sure that we don't
include individuals whose privacy budget
has been exhausted but nevertheless
there may be a good number of avid
individuals left for example on Tuesday
when you're analyzing the big population
you may have had to drop that small
number of a be negative blood type
individuals from your query but in that
particular case there were lots left so
that's the approach in the personalized
differential privacy system that we
developed but it still maybe not
completely obvious that this is privacy
preserving and there's a spoiler a first
lesson is that formal models are really
good debugging tools okay it can be very
hard to find subtle bugs in systems and
sometimes they're not so subtle in
hindsight but you can't really get that
hindsight unless sometimes you go it the
hard way around so it turns out that it
turned out that I was right and Hameed
was wrong the system was in fact broken
but fixable so it was broken in the
sense that if you think of the operation
of dropping record
from the table as a genuine
transformation prior to performing an
operation you view it as a first-class
operation in the chain then you see that
the sensitivity of that operation is
unbounded which means we can't use it
in combination with an epsilon query now
how do we fix that well it turns out
that the the reason why it becomes
unbounded is are the underlying
problematic data transformation
operators such as the general join
operation of a database how many times
does an individual get multiplied when
you join two databases well it depends
on the size of the database you join it
with and so you can't bound it so join
me is a typically problematic operation
in a differentially private enforcement
system now we we were had hoped because
we didn't need to think okay so we
you'll have to explain that afterwards
so we had hoped that because our method
was based on fine grained accounting
that you didn't have to place any
constraints on the operators and we
thought that was cool because now we can
do full joins and anything you like it
turns out we end up with the more or
less the same constraint on the basic
operations that we that pink had in the
first place that's not to say we lose
everything but it wasn't quite as cool
as we'd hoped so how do we find these
kind of bugs in systems that you might
not spot at first
well I'm arguing that we need to model
formally and this is not a formal model
this is just a sort of schematic of the
way we model the system so what is the
system well the system kind of maintains
a bunch of stuff the implementation the
heart of the system the stuff that goes
on behind the scenes that the programmer
the analyst doesn't see they only
interact with this via a fixed API and
that API looks just like
operations to apply differentially
private primitive operations update
tables using sequel like operations and
so on okay so we're gonna do some
modeling here so let me tell you a
little bit about how we went about this
so firstly how should we model a client
program this is the this is potentially
malicious if you like analyst
who is trying to break our system by
applying queries in some way that we
maybe didn't think of so what is a good
model for this well if you if you look
at pink you could say well pink really
is a seat it's a c-sharp program so we
should have a model of c-sharp here well
that's probably a unrealistic but B
actually you actually care about what
programming languages you use in such a
system because we are assuming that we
have an unbreakable API here okay
that there's no way to bypass this API
and get raw access to the data and many
programming languages it's actually
impossible to do that I mean literally
impossible good example would be I think
Python the whole philosophy of the
Python programming language is that I
think they use the phrase we're all
consenting adults which kind of means we
don't need to give you any restrictions
on what you do and what that means is
you can do all sorts of cool things
except prevent people from doing things
like bypassing an API and getting to the
internals of some system so it does
matter what program you use we couldn't
model c-sharp even if it was a feasible
thing to do what about an idealized
program so this is something you see in
programming language research a lot you
take an idealized programming language a
simply typed lambda calculus or a while
language if you're doing something like
halt logic or so an idealized programmer
see this a lot in works modeling
information flow properties of systems
you take an idealized language but
there's something important about this
and then is that the syntax in here is
not relevant other than the fact that it
speaks the language of the API there's
nothing about the syntax which is
important because we're not implementing
a type system we're not having to
analyze the syntax in order to build a
semantic model of the program the only
thing we care about is the fact that we
are doing a certain sequence of a API
calls so this in some sense would be
building in certain invariants about the
way we use an API which have no real
relevance to the problem so that doesn't
seem really a good idea either that's
that's in some sense unnecessary
simplification all right so what do we
do this in between how about just
abstracting this by a sequence of API
calls after all the API is all that
matters right okay let me give you some
cautionary tales from from studying
information flow and it goes back a long
way in fact if you trace it back it goes
back to a paper of Shannon in 58 where
he was viewing this is a good thing hey
look guys we can transform transfer more
information you know that's that's great
in the security context that's usually
not so great and so this has been
studied by a number of people I think
independently with bold and Johnston
spotted this this behavior so let's
imagine a system here trying to simplify
a little bit which has some component
some trusted component a bit like this
where you think of this is the way we're
modeling the client program here and we
have some system here and some secrets
going to come in the top and something
which we hope is not a secret coming out
the bottom and there's some interaction
between the two
so now let's instantiate P with the
following little program so P generates
a uniformly distributed bit flips a coin
which we're going to call a key and we
assume that H can see this key outputs
it to H and now it's going to input
something which we presume is some sort
of secret because it could be depending
on this guy and what it does is output
the key ex-ored with the the bit that it
was I'm assuming this is a bit as well
okay so I've generated a one-time pad
and I've encrypted the data that I'm
sending out so it doesn't really matter
you could argue here it doesn't really
matter what you received from H what I'm
sending out is noise okay pure noise so
if we model the behavior of H as a
sequence of outputs this system is 0
differentially private in other words it
has no information flow it's non
interfering with regard to the input at
the top ok that's what happens if you
model H as a sequence however if instead
you model H as a program then something
else happens here's the program H is
going to input the secret from the
outside and it's going to grab the key
that this guy generated and then it's
going to pass the key ex-ored with the
secret to P so what happens now when we
run this program
well this encrypts the data
here but the thing that it's encrypted
is H XOR with the key in other words
this is a decryption of the secret so
almost the difference between those two
models of the system in one model we
viewed we abstracted the behavior of a
component of the system as a stream of
values but when we replace the model of
us as a stream with a model as an active
process as a strategy if you will then
the then we see that this is not a safe
system from the security point of view
so it really matters how you do this
kind of modeling okay now I can give
very quickly there's I have an example
of this that arose in my own work and it
relates to privacy I'm running a bit
short in time but I think this is quite
cute what I didn't think it was that
cute at the time I discovered it but
anyway so we were modeling an ocean of
information Eurasia so information
erasure is this idea that and I think
it's embodied in in some European some
parts of the GDP our legislation is that
you know once you've used the
information for the purpose which you
gathered it then you should erase it
that's that's roughly the idea so we
were asking the question what does that
mean a from a from a semantic point of
view and B how do we enforce it and in
this particular case we're interested in
enforcing using type systems but in
order to enforce it we need to know what
we're enforcing what is a semantic model
of information or Asia so here's a
little example I have a credit card
transaction going on in this bit of code
the time line running down from top to
bottom I receive a credit card that's
the the interesting data that it's
subject to an erasure policy the erasure
policy is when the transaction is
complete you should erase the data and
what a raising the data means from our
point of view is not just that you seem
tactically delete the these digits from
some place in memory but any influence
of those digits on anything else which
is observable later on in the event in
the inter
action of the system okay however during
the time when it has access to the
credit card it may indeed communicate it
to the bank and so on okay so we studied
how to specify this and how to enforce
this that's great but a model of the
outside world was not explicit it was
implicit
and by being implicit effectively what
we ended up doing was making the same
mistake we were modeling the outside
world as a passive stream of inputs and
outputs so here's what can go wrong when
you initiate your transaction maybe a
cookie is set in your machine or maybe
you even think if you get a special
offer code thanks for shopping with us
here's your special offer next time you
come back we'll give you a 25% discount
and then indeed later on you can use
your 25% discount to get a reduced
purchase on your next interaction
however this thing here could be just an
encryption of your credit card number so
what you've done is that by using a
clever strategy out here information has
escaped the system this time not by
malicious it's not by a malicious user
the user is not malicious in storing a
cookie and retrieving that cookie but
what they're doing is acting on behalf
of the attacker to save the data which
was supposed to be erased outside of the
system and reintroduce it again
okay let me get back to the main thread
how should then should we model a client
program well I would argue that without
further evidence that it's safe to do
something simpler
we must model this as an active program
in some form however we shouldn't model
it as a particular program in a
particular toy language because the
language is not important in a dynamic
enforcement system so what we did in
fact was model it is an arbitrary
transition system in which the states of
the system are completely abstract we
say we don't know what the states are we
don't know what the programming language
is what its memory model is anything we
have States and it interacts with the
outside world
however by modeling in that way we model
the possibility that it interacts in a
way which allows us to cover these cases
of the cunning active adversary and so
that means that correct a correctness
proof for this system must quantify over
all possible such programs which run
here without having to detail them and
in fact that's not too difficult to do
ok so if I'm going to extract a lesson
from this abstractly make attacker
models as simple as possible but but no
simpler that doesn't sound very very
good but at least I would say don't
needlessly over specify in particular
dynamic enforcement mechanisms such as
reference monitors in general and not
about languages they're about interfaces
okay one other comment that I'd like to
mention is you know it's very tempting
in a system like this it's an
interactive system outputs are generated
sort of one after the other over time
it's very tempting to say okay we're
going to do something like differential
privacy for this system but we'll kind
of tweak it to fit the fact that we're
not doing just a simple function with
inputs and outputs and you can do that
and it's tend to do that but you never
quite know what you've got I mean lots
of people have studied differential
privacy for one or two definitions you
start introducing definitions which are
little tweaks and variants of this
that's not the same as a generalization
it's really not so convincing anymore
what you've actually done so I think
it's a really good idea to sort of do
the best effort to reduce the model the
reasoning about the model to the
standard case rather than modify the
standard case to some case that fits the
model and how how did we do that in this
particular case well what's tricky here
is that we don't have a single output we
have many outputs and in fact we could
have infinitely many outputs we happen
to have outputs which are 0
differentially private we will never
exhaust any budgets and we might go on
forever so how do we talk about regular
differential privacy in this context
well the way that we did this was to
view each prefix of the output stream
which corresponds to an observer or an
attacker if you will who's observing a
system for a particular duration of time
so once I chose I've chosen how long I'm
going to observe the system for then I
get a prefix of this potentially
infinite trace and what we can do is we
can model the system as a probabilistic
process that that output of course will
be subject to various coin flips along
the way so that there will be a
probability associated to that output
and what is that probability it's the
probability of observing that out
put among all outputs of the same length
in other words once you once I've
choosen chosen to observe three outputs
then there will be a probability
distributions of prefixes of the output
traces projected down to those of length
three and by doing that what we have is
a family of functions indexed by the
length of observation we make of the
system and what we're showing is that
for each member of that family of
functions they satisfy regular ordinary
epsilon differential privacy
okay so the ideas that we developed
along the way to proving properties
about this not obviously correct in fact
not correct when we started system we've
taken those lessons and distilled them
into something somewhat simpler
basically revisiting the pink system
which is a real system and building a
little model of it in some ways the most
lightweight model we could think of
which was arguably faithful to the
original design that I think that we
would like to offer as a useful starting
point for modeling extensions and
variants of these kind of dynamic
differential privacy systems so let me
wrap up in my last few minutes
conclusions
well I've shown you a few
bumps along the way in in formalizing
but what I hope to convey to you is that
there is there is value in building
rigorous models of not just the core
components and the basic principles you
use to put them together but a bit more
top-down the system as a whole and how
they are how that can be decomposed into
its pieces and so making attack on
models as simple as possible but you've
got to be careful
don't over specify where you don't need
to because you're proving weaker
properties in that case I don't know why
there's a number on that lesson and if
you can reduce to the standard case
rather than adapting the standard case
to your situation and then the final
conclusion as I say I think formal
models have for me have been very good
debugging tools one can go a step
further and making them both formal and
machine checked and that's the general
trend in in the programming languages
community but I think even without full
mechanical proof building formal models
of your design is a very useful thing
and I thoroughly recommend it and they
even pay me for it so it's awesome thank
you very much
[Applause]
I want to understand this trades concept
a little a little better it Sal
it seems I'm smaller in spirit to what
in the crypto world we've called the
view of an adversary interacting with
the system whatever random is they
started with and then the you know their
entire view of the interaction with the
interactive system and they're there we
wouldn't typically we talk you know we
can talk about a system
indistinguishability with respect to an
adversary interact with system in terms
of in terms of the views being you know
having similar distribution under to two
different inputs or two different
neighboring databases and there we
wouldn't typically restrict the length
of the interaction we were to say it's a
probability distribution on on on you
know strings of unbounded lengths right
and aspect for every set of possible
strings the probabilities are close so
I'm just so we could have done here is
is even you know so you'd have to model
this as unbounded or infinite so that's
that's the domain and you could
associate a probability distribution
with each of those complete things I
guess what I would be what concerned
about then is okay but what if I'm not
willing to sit and watch this infinite
output or arbitrarily long what if I
just see some of it and decide to stop
the system and indeed if you look at the
interaction between the inputs and the
outputs in fact I think there are
information leaks that you could hide if
you ignored the fact that this this
trace has a kind of causal structure
that relates to the inputs there is more
structure in understanding the partial
that all the partial things together
than there is when you just look at the
limit is not that it halting part of the
strategy of the the client program that
because you universally quantify over
the know it so I think there's two
different parts of this the client
program and then the observer which you
kind of think of as separately but the
observer is maybe the one that can press
ctrl C which is outside of the program I
mean I think there are some subtleties
there it could be that you can you can
argue that it's enough to think of the
distribution of the whole output space
in one go but from the point of you're
proving it was very convenient to do it
this way because it gives us a kind of
inductive handle on things and you know
the proofs here not like typical crypto
proofs them is just doing induction over
definitions of the way the computation
of the system proceeds we're imagining
is maybe like with epsilon Delta
differential privacy this truncation
yeah so I think about epsilon Delta is
there I mean what you don't see clearly
in the definition when you look at the
rarefied definitions in the in the
adaptiveness properties
and I think you realize it much more
clearly when you build a system on
because you cannot avoid the it's not
just adaptivity in the way there are
people often assume adaptivity that's
just where the results of one query can
be used to determine the next query but
often people are assuming that the next
query the epsilon is already fixed and
what you find is that in when you
implement when you model it the way it
really is
you suddenly realize actually that they
you wouldn't barely use that as in in
the proof because the epsilon is not is
adaptive as well and that's very easy to
miss when you're doing just focusing on
sort of abstracting out the high-level
principles you might not have quite
general enough principles for the system
at hand going the other way modeling the
system directly you have no choice and
you're going to hit that you'll see
Murphy's Law tells you it'll be in the
last proof case where you'll find it but
that's the way things are
if we have time otherwise I'll take it
offline I did John's question a little
bit so this is going back to the
personalized yeah yep so when you
mentioned that the inside the system the
the personalized budgets then become
that's kind of suggesting a that the
definition is saying something like the
person's data is there is there their
data record and their Epsilon and when
you when you add someone or remove
someone from a data set you're adding a
data item and now with an epsilon kind
of you know that sounds like an elegant
way to handle it and maybe we'd thought
about it that way from the beginning we
might have defined it that way but we do
keep them separate we kind of view the
epsilon as coming from this you know
global platonic sort of map between
records and and budgets so we kind of
push that outside of the system you say
a word about how you handle the the
worry that you described I mean just
saying that you got to get rid of joined
wasn't like enough for me to get a sense
yeah okay so so basically by getting rid
of so so you restrict to a certain class
of of operations on the data which have
a sort of join preserve Union preserving
property over the the sets of data the
record the sets of records and that
condition is enough to guarantee that
the sensitivity of the the number of
records which you delete is is
relatively low so the sensitivity of the
of the deletion operation that takes
place before the query is low so that's
thanks
they'll just just clarify is the only
reason why you need to keep the
individual privacy budget private
because of the fact that changing that
inherently reveals whether you've
contributed to well so it could be if
you wanted to if you liked the idea that
somebody should have a personalized that
you should be able to set your own
personal budget on your data then we
could plug that in to the system and
start where everybody has their own real
personal budget but if you did that it's
probably the case that you would like to
keep it secret
because the fact that you view your data
is much more sensitive than I do maybe
makes you a sort of target you know why
why are your medical why are you making
your reddick medical records so secret
you know maybe we should have raised
your insurance so in that case the fact
that the we treated as if it was
sensitive from the beginning even though
we don't need to at the very beginning
could be used for for for really setting
a personalized sensitive
[Applause]